Do we have other evidence that Jerusalem
is no longer God's
city and the Jews are no longer his
kingdom, his people on earth? Yeah.
Let's wrap it up and I'll add this to my
series. All right. Matthew 8:5-13.
Pay attention. A centurion,
a gentile,
a leader of 100 soldiers, part of the
Roman Empire occupying Israel. Look what
Jesus says about him and the shot he
takes against him. All right,
you with me there? Now, let me I'm going
to wrap it up by showing you Jerusalem
on earth is an abomination to God.
Jerusalem on earth is no longer the real
Jerusalem. No longer. It's done. It's
over.
Capich n the New Testament says this
Jerusalem
is evil. This Jerusalem is of Satan.
This Jerusalem is Hagar. This Jerusalem
is Sodom. It's Egypt.
So what's the real Jerusalem? The one
that comes down from heaven. Okay? And
we're done.
There are no more land promises for
Israel. It's done. The only promise
left, Romans 11. So are there any
promises for the Jews? Only one. Until
Jesus returns, God will not wipe out
Israel
completely. Well, there will be no more
Jews living on earth. That's his only
promise. The Jews will continue to have
seed, those who are physically Jews,
until Christ returns. He won't wipe them
out and erase them as a people. But
nothing to do with the land. Nothing to
do with the land. Nothing to do with the
land.
Okay, that's over with. Here it is.
Matthew 85-13.
And when Jesus entered Capernaum, a
centurion came to him pleading with him
and saying, "Lord, my servant is lying
lying paralyzed at home, fearfully
tormented. And Jesus said to him, I will
come and heal him." But the centurion
said, "Lord, I am not good enough for
you to come under my roof, but just say
the word and my servant will be healed.
For I also am a man under authority with
soldiers under me. And I say this to a
man, go. And he goes, and to another,
"Come," and he comes. And to my slave,
"Do this," and he does it. Now when
Jesus heard this, he marveled and said
to those who are following, "Truly I say
to you, I have not found such great
faith with anyone in Israel." You know,
that is the worst dagger in the heart of
a Jew. to say a Roman, a gentile who is
a centurion, a soldier who has 100
soldiers underneath him is better than
all of Israel combined when it comes to
faith. None of you Jews can match this
gentile soldier's faith.
And this is the Jew Jesus saying it.
See why the rabbis and the Pharisees
hated him?
All right. Do you see why the rabbis
Pharisees hated him? We're almost done.
And I say to you that many will come
from east and west, meaning Gentiles,
the nations, and they will recline with
Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob. He's now
rubbing it in their face, in the kingdom
of heaven. But the sons of the kingdom,
meaning you Jews, will be cast into the
outer darkness, and that place there'll
be weeping, nashing of teeth. Can it be
any clearer, man?
Jesus is not a Zionist.
Jesus is not a Zionist. He said the sons
of the kingdom, meaning Israel, you were
given the kingdom. You'll be in hell,
whereas the Gentiles from all over the
world will be sitting with your fathers.
Like he's rubbing it in their face.
He's rubbing it in their face.
See why they hate him? And Jesus said to
century, "Go, it shall be done for you
as you have believed." Then the servant
was healed that very moment. All right,
here you go. How do we know it's over
for Israel as a nation and the land
promises are done away with? Here it is.
Jesus says it black and white. I'm not
going to reread Matthew 23 and 24. Just
here the parable. Matthew 21:33-44.
Listen to another parable. This Jesus
speaking. There was a landowner who
planted a vineyard. vineyard is
Jerusalem and put a a wall around it and
dug a wine press in it and built a tower
and rent it out to vine growers and went
on the journey. The vine growers are the
leaders of Jerusalem. He's going to
explain it now. And when the the harvest
time approached, he sent his slaves to
the vine growers to receive his fruit.
According to Jeremiah 7:25,
Jeremiah 26:5,
Jeremiah 29:19, and 44:4, the slaves are
the prophets. Let me just give you a few
examples
so you know who he's talking about.
Isaiah 5:1-7 says, "Is a vineyard is
Israel." Not going to quote that, but I
just want to show you who
the slaves are supposed to be. Okay?
See, Jesus is building on Old Testament
imagery. Isaiah 51:7 says, "The vineyard
is Israel." Go read it. Isaiah 517, "The
slaves were the prophet sent to you."
Okay, let's go so you don't think I'm
lying. Here you go. Jeremiah 7:25. Since
the day that your fathers came out of
the land of Egypt, and to this day I've
sent you all my slaves, the prophets,
daily rising up early and sending them.
All right.
Who are the slaves? The prophets.
Jeremiah 26:5. To listen to the words of
my slaves, the prophets, whom I have
been sending to you, rising up early and
sending, but you have not listened. All
right. 29:19 Jeremiah. Because they have
not listened to my words, declares
Yahweh, which I have sent to them by my
slaves, the prophets, rising up early
and sending. But you did not listen,
declares Yahweh. All right. Still not
convinced. Jeremiah 44:4. Yet I sent you
all my slaves, the prophets, rising up
early and sending, saying, "Oh, do not
do this abominal thing, abominal thing
which I hate." So now you know who the
slaves are in the parable. Right?
The prophets. The owner is the father.
The vineyard is Jerusalem. The vine
dressers are
the leaders. The slaves are the
prophets. So how do they treat them?
And the vine growers took his slaves and
beat one and killed another and stoned a
third. And he sent another group of
slaves larger than the first. And they
did the same thing to them. Now, who
does Jesus think he is? Notice in this
parable, Jesus is not a mere human
slave, a prophet. He is the beloved son
of the owner and his heir. He owns
everything the owner owns. So, how do we
know it's over for Israel? But afterward
he sent his son to them saying they
respect my son. So notice Jesus says I'm
not a mere human slave, mere human
prophet. I'm greater than them. I am the
unique son of the owner. So God is the
owner. I'm his son. I'm the heir. I own
all he possesses. Meaning I own the
slaves. So the prophets are my slaves
too because I'm the heir. I own you and
I own Jerusalem.
See who Jesus just made himself out to
be.
But when the vine growers saw the son,
they said among themselves, "This is the
heir. Come, let us kill him and seize
his inheritance." And they took him and
threw him out of the vineyard and killed
him. See, he goes, "I was your last
chance, but I'm going to tell you what
you're going to do to me before you do
it. And then I'm going to tell you what
your judgment is. Look, you're going to
kill me." And guess what? God is going
to destroy you, your city, and get rid
of you and throw you out of the land.
And it's over. Why it's over? Because
then I'm going to give the kingdom to a
new people.
Here you go. I'm not lying. Therefore,
when the owner of the vineyard comes,
what will he do to those vine growers?
They said to him, he'll bring those
wretches to a wretched end. Will rent
out the vineyard to other vine growers
who will pay him the pro proceeds,
right?
All right. Proceeds.
Pay him the proceeds
at the proper season. Do you see that?
He's going to kill and get rid of those
vineyard and replace them with others.
They even said, "So, they're bearing
witness against them." Little they
realize he's talking about them. Jesus
said to them, "Did you never read in the
scriptures the stone which the builders
rejected? This has become the chief
cornerstone.
This came about from the Lord and his
marvels in our eyes. Now watch.
Therefore, I say to you, the king God
will be taken away from you and given to
a nation producing the fruit of it.
Where does Jesus's teaching leave room
for the Jews being his chosen people who
return to the land and take the land
over?
Perhaps that's why they need DNA
testing.
All right. Can it be any clearer?
Therefore, I say to you, the kingdom of
God will be taken away from you and
given to a nation producing the fruit of
it. Where does this leave? Israel and
the land. And he who falls on the stone,
me, will be broken to pieces. You'll be
broken to repentance. But if I fall on
you, I will crush you and scatter you
like dust. He's saying to the Jews, when
my wrath is unleashed on you,
I will then scatter you like dust, which
he did.
Temple destroyed, Jerusalem destroyed.
They were scattered like dust all over
the world for over 1900 years.
See it?
So then, who are the people of God, the
Israel of God, the nation that will be
given the kingdom?
Okay, he says it right here, right?
The kingdom is not yours anymore. It's
done. He says it right here. Let's see.
Let's see. You ready?
First of all, what does
God think of Jerusalem now? This
Jerusalem on earth.
What does God think of this Jerusalem on
earth?
Okay, watch here.
Get ready. We're almost done.
And we're going to read from 41 to 13.
Uh 17. Let's read 17. We're done right
here. You guys enjoy this? I'll come
back and do Dustin Smith tonight.
All right. Galatians 4:21-26.
Tell me, you who want to be under law,
do you not listen to the law? For it is
written that Abraham had two sons, one
by the servant woman and one by the free
woman. But the son by the servant woman,
I'm gonna include all the way to 31, but
I'll come back to the rest of it later
because we're going to go out with a
bang. And I'm gonna add it to my series
and retitle this
right
son of right now. I don't know if you're
here, but I hope you enjoyed it. Tell me
you who want to be under law, do you not
listen to the law? For it is written
that Abraham had two sons, one by the
servant woman and one by the free woman.
But the son by the servant woman who had
been born according flesh while the son
by the free woman through the pro.
Remember this. It's those who are
children of the promise that are Israel.
Keep that in mind. Cat wants to go. Keep
that in mind. Remember this. This is the
this is the this is spoken with
allegory. Sorry. Lord loosen my tongue.
For these women are two covenants. One.
Right. Come here. Let's see if this cat
wants to go out. This cat man. All
right. Watch here. Watch here.
While the son of the woman, sorry about
that. By the free woman through the
prom. Now remember the promise. The
children are promised are Israel. Pay
attention. This is spoken with allegory.
So Hagar and Sarah serve as an allegory
for two cities.
Two cities. This is spoken with
allegory. For these women are two
covenants. one from Mount Sai bearing
children into slavery. She is Hagar. Now
this Hagar is Mount Sai in Arabia and
corresponds to the present Jerusalem for
she's in slavery to children. Paul just
told you earthly Jerusalem is Hagar
and the Jews
who follow the law of Sai are Ishelites.
They're not Jews.
He just said Tovia Singer, that bastard
of Satan, he's not a real Israelite.
He's not a Jew. He's spiritually an
Ishelite. His mother is Hagar.
Netanyahu is an Ishelite. His mother is
Hagar.
By the way, Divine, maybe tonight you
want to join me. We'll do Dustin Smith.
His mother is Hagar.
These are Hagarites.
Spiritually they are sons and daughters
of Hagar. Their ancestors Ishmael, not
Isaac. Paul the Jew just said that.
You see that rumble? Paul the Jew, not a
non-Jew.
Paul the Jew.
See that rumble?
You shocked. Now remember, you should
know this. I did a series on it. I'm
gonna add this to the playlist.
But the Jerusalem above is free. She is
our mother.
There's two Jerusalems. The heavenly one
will come down and replace the one on
earth. So it's no longer the Jerusalem
on earth. We're waiting for the
Jerusalem in heaven to come down. I'm
going to come back to this later.
Remember, it's the children of promise,
right? Okay.
Hebrews 12:22-24.
How many Jerusalems? And which one is
the real Jerusalem? Hebrews 12:22:24.
But you have come to Mount Zion, to the
city of the living God, the heavenly
Jerusalem, and to myriads of angels, to
the festal gathering, meaning the
church, assembly of the firstborn. Those
who first converted and died are now in
heaven, are enrolled in heaven. Wait,
there's a heavenly Jerusalem. And the
believers who died are perfected, and
they're there as spirits. their bodies
in the dust and angels are there in
heaven and God is there. So you see God
in his visible glory to judge of all
spirits of the righteous made perfect.
Notice their spirits are there not their
bodies because there's no such thing as
soul sleep. If we die I plead the blood
of Jesus on us to wash us. We enter
directly and Jesus is there in his
glorified physical body mediating as the
high priest of the new covenant. And he
presents the blood that he sprinkled
that washes us to the father which
speaks salvation not judgment because it
speaks a better word than the blood of
Abel because the blood of Abel cried out
to God avenge me. The blood of Christ
says forgive them.
Okay.
So the heavenly Jerusalem and what will
come down on earth? The heavenly
Jerusalem. That earthly one is no of no
use.
Revelation 21:104 Then I saw a new
heaven, new earth, for the first heaven
and first earth passed away, and there
is no longer any sea. And I saw the holy
city, new Jerusalem, coming down out
from heaven. Notice it, the Jerusalem
above, the heavenly Jerusalem. She's the
real Jerusalem. She's our mother, the
bride of Christ. She's coming down,
supplanting, usurping, swelling up
earthly Jerusalem,
right?
is there made ready as a bride adorned
for her husband and I heard a loud voice
from the throne saying behold the
tabernacle of God is among them because
where God is that's where Jerusalem will
be
and he will dwell among them and they
shall be his people and God himself will
be among them he'll wipe away every tear
from their eyes there will no longer be
any death there will no longer be any
mourning or crying or pain their first
things passed away so Paul called the
Jerusalem on earth Hagar what does John
call it Revelation 11:8.
And their dead bodies will lie in the
street of the great city which is
spiritual which spiritually is called
Sodom and Egypt where also their Lord
was crucified. Well, Christ was killed
in Jerusalem.
John said earthly Jerusalem is Sodom and
Egypt.
Paul said it's Hagar. How then
are you honoring earthly Jerusalem?
John says that's the place where your
Lord was killed, crucified. And God
hates that place because he says it's
Sodom and Egypt. And you know what he
did to Sodom, right? And did to Egypt.
And God calls it Hagar.
So why do you honor it?